on voir un reportage qui se passe du
côté de blois votre ville donc ou
yannick noah donc tente de démocratiser
plus encore le tennis le tennis qui
avait connu un gros bout vous le savez
il ya quelques années un petit
essoufflement il y a quelques mois il
faut relancer ça passe par des
opérations comme celle réussie à blois
par yannick noah voyez le reportage de
christelle bertrand et jean paul
chaussée
construire un mur dans la cité pour une
fois tout le monde trouve que c'est une
bonne idée alors sur leur mur les
enfants voulu signer et quand yannick
noah vient d'inaugurer s'est à son tour
de tous dédicacés nord et président de
l'association fête le mur un mur pour
que les enfants des cités puissent eux
aussi jouer au tennis
il n'y a pas de raison au milieu du
béton on peut aussi devenir un champion
et les grands joueurs de tenerife tous
les champions a commencé contrairement à
l'or contre le mur qui jouent la finale
des dames contre le mur r en demi finale
est roland garros et ses débuts du rêve
quoi
or seuls dans les cités le mur boursiers
plutôt c'est pas synonyme de rêve c'est
sur un vrai court de tennis qu'on rêve
encore un peu plus l'association a fait
remettre en état de terrain délabré le
tee shirt et grands laraque est un peu
lourde mais tout le monde s'implique
parce qu'en face l'adversaire a gagné
roland garros
normal après des années de pratique et
de compétition aujourd'hui sur un court
noah dirige la leçon
l'association a déjà implanté cinq sites
en france dans les cités noah est un
modèle et quand il s'agit de faire la
fête
il est toujours d'accord pour montrer
l'exemple